皆さんは
自分が死を迎える時
最後の瞬間を迎えるときについて
想像したことは
ありますか
あなたはその時
どのような
空間にいて
そして誰と一緒にいて
どんな音を聞いて
どんな匂いを嗅い0
そして一緒にいる人と
どのような話をしているでしょうか
現在日本では
約80%近くの人だっ
病院で死を迎えます
つまり
5人のうち4人が病院での死を迎えます
これは日本の
一般的な病棟の姿です
想像してみてください
あなたはだいたい70歳ぐらい
ここのベッドに寝ています
大病を患い
徐々に
体を動かすのもしんどくなってきます
ご飯も少しずつ
喉通らなくなっていきます
腕を上げることも
体を起こすこともだんだん難しくなっていきます
きっと痛みや何かもあることでしょう
あなたはそのベッドの上で
寝たまま
天井を見上げています
天井にはいつついたか分からないようなちょっと親しみがあって
周りを取り囲むのは
真っ白な壁と
カーテン
そして
なんとなく自分と離れたところにあるような
世界にあるようなテレビが一つ
何となく想像し世界が隣にあります
代わり映えのない世界を
ゆっくりと見ていることになります
これを想像したときみなさんはどう思いますでしょうか
僕はこれを創造したときにちょっと寂しいかなと
今まで生きてきた素晴らしい人生の最期
真っ白な壁
想像しテレビ
なんとなくシミのついた汚れた天井
それを見上げて最後を終えてしまう
なんとなく切ないなと思います
ここには
大病を患い
患って
60代半ばのお母さんが
娘さんと一緒に天井を見上げています
先ほど想像したように
ご飯も少しずつ食べれなくなっていて
体に痛みもあります
本当は薄めさんといっぱいいっぱい話したいのに
痛みが強かったり
息が苦しかったり
少しずつ一緒に過ごすのも大変な時もあります
隣の娘さんは
僕と同じくらいの年齢
20代半ばから後半の女性です
この2人は
今
同じ次戦を
そして同じ体勢で
体を寄せ合いながら
声を掛け合いながら
天井を見上げていることでしょう
天井には
普段はモノクロで何もないような白い世界が広がっています
しかしこの日ばかりはプロジェクターで色とりどりの娘さんの子供時代の写真を眺めて
おります
この二人はどのような時間を過ごしたでしょうか
病院は病気になったときに
体を治す修理工場
そうではないですよね
これからの医療の現場はどのような現場であるべきでしょうか
現在
現在に至るまで
日本の医療はどんどんと進歩してきて治療技術がどんどん高まってきています
治らない病気もなるようになってきて
痛みのコントロールがすごく上手くなってきて
そして長生きもできるようになってきました
そうなるにつれて
秒キーというものは
治るもの
なわらないものというのような捉え方が
広まってきたそういう認識が大きくなってきたのではないでしょうか
病気について僕が思うこと
その本質は病気にしっかり向き合うことそれが一番大切なことなのではないかと
そう思います
今でも
多くの人々が自分のやまや
自分の姿に向き合っています
皆さんは
行病院についてなんとなく他人ごとだと思っていませんか
気付いたときに病気になってその時は他人ごと
急に自分ごとのように降りかかってくる
そして急に自分ごとになる
でもやっぱり遠い存在
僕はもう少し医療の現場や病院は身近であるべきだとそう思っています
治療についてはどんどんどんどんアップデートが繰り返されて病院が本当に日本の病院
がすごくよくなってきて世界的にもすごいよくなっています
しかし病気についての在り方や病気についてしっかりと受け入れる場所
そういうような考え方のアップデートは少し遅れてきた
遅れて来てしまったのではないかなと思っております
僕は先ほど病院が医療の現場がもっともっと身近であるべきだ
そういうように話したと思います
しかし実際は医療の現場や社会そしてその他の領域はまだまだ大きな壁があると思って
います
僕はその大きな壁を乗り越えていくための鍵が
アート
テクノロジーだと
そう考えて
日々のプロジェクト
実施しています
テクノロジーは医療医療やコミュニケーション革新的に
アートはその特性が持つ余剰が医療の現場とテクノロジよう
調和していきます
この写真を見てください
この写真は
女のセンサー
目線のセンサーを女の目の向きを取るセンサーです
彼は目を使ってカーソルを動かし色を選択肢選んだ色がプロジェクターから出力され
部屋の色が変わります
すごく簡単な仕組みです
これを実施してくれたのは筋ジストロフィーという病気を持っている方です
徐々に筋力が衰えていき
自分のできることが少しずつ減っていく
それに向き合わなければなりません
彼はこれを実施スターぷにゲームだしたい
そういうふうに話していました
今までそういうことを聞いたことはなかったとその場の看護師さんは言ってたんです
けど
これ自体が未来への希望の光ではないかと
そう思いました
そして病院の看護師さんからもこういう話が聞かれました
同じような病気を持っていた人で
すごく俳句を書くなひっかくのが好きな人がいたんだけど
その人がどんどん書けなくなっていくのが少し悲しかったな
そしてその人もなんとなく寂しそうにしてたなと
だけどこういうものがあったらもしかしたら最後までとは言わなくてももうちょっと
長く
俳句を書くことができたんじゃないかなと
そういうふうに話していました
この病院では
先ほどのプロジェクト実施した後にまだまだ
自主的にプロジェクトを続けて言ってくださっています
七夕の時期には星を見せてあげたい
そういう思いでスタッフの皆さんが協力して実施してくれました
手を動かすとカーソルが動いて星が流れたり星座が現れたり
そういったデジタルアートです
医療のスタッフの方が
小さな子どもの手を取り一緒に手をかざして
ですタラート楽しんでいます
リハビリをする時にいつも筋肉はこわばっていたこの子ですがこの時ばかりは
一緒に筋肉を緩めて楽しんでいたそうです
スタッフの皆さんからも笑顔がこぼれていました
テクノロジーは今後どんどんどんどん発展していきます
コミュニケーションが難しいハンディキャップを背負った人も自由に
コミュニケーションを取ったり自由に表現したり
そして
最後まで自分の好きな音楽を選んだり好きな映画を見たりそういうことが当たり前に
なってくると思います
病院にいる彼らだからこそいろいろな表現ができる
そういう子なって表れてくるかもしれません
彼はイベントのときに一緒にダンスバトルを繰り広げた
少年です
車椅子生活をしている中学生
普段支えられた wii のコントローラーを使って
ランサーの影を操っています
憧れのダンサーと一緒にダンスパフォーマンスをして周りを沸かせました
人は
病を患った時に
とても辛い思いをします
して
僕らみんなは
これからしについて向き合っていくことになります
それは自分の子
だけでなく身近な人の死
向き合っていかないければならない時が来るかもしれません
僕らには何ができるでしょうか
生きているすべての人病気を抱えている人障害を持っている人と
真剣に向き合う
そしてこれから死を迎えていく人と真正面から向き合うことが大切ではないでしょうか
最後にもう一度この写真を見てください
皆さんはこの写真を見たとき
自分ならどういうことをしてほしい
これが家族ならどういうことをしてあげたい
そういうふうに思った事などありませんでしょうか
その一つ一つが
医療の現場をよくしていくアイディアになります
皆さんがアイディア小さなものを積み重ねていくことで
医療の現場は本当によくなっていきます
これからの医療の現場をつくっていくのは
僕たちそしてここに会場にいる人
みんなになると思います
こうしてみんなで作っていった一つ一つの笑顔が
きっと病院以外の世界を明るくしていくことでしょう
そして
病院が開かれていって医療の現場が開かれていって
社会と共に同じ方向を向いていく
そうした時にもっともっと外に出て行った人が新しい世界をつくっていく
そういう世界がこれからの素敵な医療の姿ではないでしょうか
ありがとうございました